uma bom dia gente brasil está aqui vou
falar um pouco sobre aspectos de
comunicação é poucas teorias august anos
muito pautado no que a gente está vendo
hoje em dia é nessa mudança nessa
ruptura na forma de comunicação como o
que a gente pode ter uma capilaridade
absurda de canais de comunicação de
forma de se comunicar das empresas mais
milionários do mundo não terem uma
estrutura física e ainda assim em termos
gráficos e estatísticas tão macabras
como 78% dos executivos brasileiros têm
pavor de falar em público ou 82% da
população prefere a morte a falar em
público pode acertar no palco você de
maio morre bom
qual é a minha história eu sou um ex
time de muito dinheiro
o time do ponto de evitar a chamada era
um desespero
augusto todos amiguinhos olhavam para
mim a não ser que tivesse algum abraão
na turma que não era o caso eu era o
primeiro da chamada e era desesperador
porque eu era uma criança feia eu me
achava uma criança feia com dois anos a
minha mãe teve uma atitude fantástica
pegou um esparadrapo e coloco me colocou
aqui assim que eu falei de orelha de
abano o médico falou não faça isso por
favor
a coisa foi piorando e na sala de aula
era desesperador eu me sentia não me
achava interessante era uma criança feia
e era uma fase muito ruim porque eu vou
chegar atrasado e aí eu pedi o chamado e
é reprovado não tinha muita opção e eu
me sentia assim quando chegava em sala
de aula
por seu turno não vai ficar 1 augusto
com o tempo isso vai melhorar então tem
quem tem criança sabia criança é um é um
bicho perverso e aí alguém teve uma
idéia é ótima
eu estava pulando corda alguém falou tá
vendo aquele bicho feio vamos fazer um
foguinho pra ele sabe que o foguinho é
você acelerar
ah ah ah aquele negócio acorda e fica
pulando quem dança música da bahia e
aquele negócio enrolou no meu joelho ao
cair com o queixo no chão sangue do
hospital
a partir daí eu tive que usar isso aqui
alguém que usou isso o vovô levanta a
mão aí gente
nós só um sobrevivente
a ortodontia não utiliza mas isso devido
à quantidade de suicídio de crianças não
existe mais esse negócio e para piorar
eu era apaixonado por uma menininha
essa música e senha
gente por agente produtivo
melhorar tá bom eu cresci então era
gordinho estiquei sabe aquelas crianças
que chicão só que fiquei com muita
espinha e eo meu cabelo era meio louro
não sei por que ele não conhecia para
baixo ele crescer pra cima e ela é uma
mistura de uns o kido com o cabelo louro
então pareciam fandangos e alguém falou
nossa você é a cara daquele vocalista do
ipop quando estava pensando em me matar
alguém falou augusta
você é a cara do ator do gols
imagine olhe não abarca você é a cara do
fantasma do vaga porque eu só tinha
comunicação pra aparecer com esse
histórico que vai fazer nada eu só podia
me comunicar e eu comecei a perceber que
as pessoas interessantes se comunicavam
que não tinha relação com beleza que
tinha com sobrevivência ou acabam depois
eu fiz faculdade de comunicação e agora
dou aula de comunicação e trabalho em
comunicação
escrevi pra gol então é isso foi
extremamente positivo ea maioria dos
autores american humoristas tiveram uma
infância meio trágica e toda essa volta
para chegar nesse lugar aqui como está a
comunicação hoje que está acontecendo
com o mundo adultos usa usando livros
para colorir e crianças usando o tablet
que está acontecendo
esse aqui é o segundo baumann um dos
principais autores críticos do mundo
líquido que o mundo líquido muito em
forma
é o mundo que você tem 2 mil amigos no
facebook e ninguém vai te visitar no
hospital
é o mundo em que o contemplado foi
trocado pelo self manda rudi é um mundo
em que como é que a comunicação o que o
virtual tem mais valor que o físico pode
estar conversando com alguém o telefone
toque ignora essa pessoa levou o que
está acontecendo
com isso e aí é eu acho que o mundo está
num processo de ebulição em que a gente
tem que sair daquele modelo e eu estou
falando da escola da faculdade dom do
mundo pra esse aqui que é a diferença
clara entre o o conhecimento ea
informação informação é perecível
a informação é finita o conhecimento não
você aprendeu a andar de bicicleta você
aprendeu a dirigir eu decorei os
afluentes do rio amazonas
eu decorei capitanias hereditárias
o que esse autor fala ele faleceu em
ele é um psicanalista que ele fala que o
meu processo de aprendizado passa por
isso aqui é a hora que efetivamente
entendo então a gente tem que incentivar
para que haja uma comunicação rural para
as crianças dos filhos dos executivos
eu tenho que ensinar para ensinar eu
tenho que aprender
eu não tenho que decorar vamos melhorar
isso
esse é um modelo de educação que eu
acredito tanto em casa quanto na escola
em que eu tenho pessoas com habilidades
diferentes com características
diferentes com estilos completamente
diferentes que podem ser complementares
que o fugiu dos padrões
o mercado está comprando a diferença ea
gente está vendo o padrão sem opção
concordar comigo eu tenho um filho ruim
matemática e bom em história e contar
com um professor particular de que está
errado é quem contrata um história para
ficar o cão história e contratou o meia
boca de matemática só com o bichinho
passar
eu nunca vou potencializar o que eu não
tenho de bom
alguns aspectos
aí entra um pouco de teoria luciana
emoção no discurso da emoção no que você
fala menos razão e mais coração década
de 80 não de forma não tem cheiro não só
os tiras argumento racional a
publicidade não toca mais nisso hoje em
dia nos 30 segundos eu exploro
argumentos emocionais tempo todo porque
porque emoção gera dopamina
está aqui agora aproximadamente no mundo
está acontecendo nesse mesmo minuto 100
mil apresentações 90% delas são perda de
tempo sabe que eu roubando de vocês algo
que não volta que é o tempo de vida
eu tenho que ter muita preocupação e eu
só acredito nisso quando vem daqui se
mixto que esses caras têm em comum
independente da ideologia
visceral emocional último de costolo foi
sensacional não concorda com a ideologia
dele mas é em nenhum momento ele ora em
terceira pessoa que está aqui mais do
que isso e aí pro pessoal do youtube
está falando de comunicação oral mas
também que serve para o virtual que é o
mundo que a gente está lá
isso gera dopamina com altruísmo então
aí fica sensacional
a comunicação com altruísmo faz com que
o menino do interior de minas com uma
câmera ruim com o áudio ruim faça um
vídeo ensinando as pessoas a fazer
mágica
o menino de 12 anos e tenha meio milhão
de acessos
eu estou trocando seu tempo de vida por
altruísmo então meu discurso emocional e
no final eu percebi que eu aprendi
alguma coisa olha que coincidência a
maioria dos vídeos do ted ea maioria dos
vídeos do youtube tem esse viés
altruísta
outro aspecto naturalidade porque é tão
difícil chegar nesse lugar conhece te a
ti mesmo que ser natural o verbo eu
escrevi um novo marco veras ele fala
isso eu faço há dez anos o meu stand up
nossa parece muito natural a dez anos
que eu faço o mesmo texto ele tem
propriedade sobre o texto
quanto mais você se prepara mais chances
você tem que ser natural mas eu tenho
que tomar lhe o que eu sou não eu posso
passar pelo palco problema de quem está
filmando
se eu tenho mania de andar eu vou
potencializar o que eu já faço eu não
vou me travar por conta disso eu tenho
estimular essa naturalidade
o mercado está buscando a diferença e
não o padrão e existem modelos que
vendem exatamente calça preta camisa
branca tem o cabelo da esquerda para a
direita faz você tem três defeitos você
fala que você é que a gama workaholic
que é perfeccionista né empatia
olha que eu botei aí
não é qualquer preço eu tô preocupado
com vocês
eu me coloco no seu lugar eu visto seu
sapato eu não tive noro empatia tem
escuta plena empate é a parte mais
difícil não é dada por um filho um
iphone 6 de quatro mil reais
ele quer presença empatia feedback
empate escutar crítica e empatia
melhorar com a troca eu não me fecho nos
reinventando a roda eu tô pegando
aspectos anteriores para trazer para a
comunicação contemporânea passa por esse
aspecto tá tudo bem a imita legal
preparação porque porque o mundo líquido
ao mundo e à população precoce é o mundo
rápido tudo é pra ontem
eu preciso eu vou alimentando com isso
tem uma ansiedade absurda e aí quando eu
entro em preparação eu tenho um problema
porque eu tô me preparando e me
preparando pra vocês eu tenho que parar
por um tempo que vocês me deram
olha lá pergunta jornalística o que
quando onde e por que pra quem qual o
tempo que eu tenho minimamente assim na
pior das hipóteses de kawasaki teoria
dos 10 20 e 30 da slide para 20 minutos
com tipologia 30 porque tecnologia 30
porque obriga conhecer o meu slide
conhecer o que eu vou falar que os
professores não fazem isso lendo os
visuais eu estou disputando com a minha
platéia quem é mais rápido storytelling
outro tópico relevante contar história o
ser humano se aproxima de quem conta a
história é extremamente interessante
fazer isso no passado na época das
cavernas conta a história conta a
história tem mais valor do que gráfico
do que o infográfico do que estatística
conta a história significa abraçado a
platéia braz ao seu público sempre que
você puder conquistaria a história passa
por uma estrutura básica início meio e
fim
entendi essa narrativa tudo funciona
videogames literatura arte teatro tudo
passa por storytelling as empresas estão
buscando exatamente esse caminho
olha lá como esse cara fazia eu vejo que
a sociedade adora música como é que
seria se você colocasse mil músicas no
seu bolso
como você faz para carregar essas
músicas
olha o herói de 12 doze campbell
pronto aí nós ele é brilhante
resolvi preparar um rapaz que vende bala
na central do brasil minimamente e
gravei caneta por apenas um real cada
pastor e moura
é barra de cereal por apenas 1 real
[Música]
olha as senhoras e senhores batalha
campal
uma barra de cereal no entanto só lhes
água é um produto vendido bem veicular
em tempo real e 40 federal e 80 na
unidade
mas por que uma vaidade serial tem
surpresa
rivais e calorias e alto teor de fibras
além de ser um marco do filme do
colesterol a libertar ninguém faz xixi
carro
[Música]
em suma esses três pilares é a minha
opinião
incentivem minimamente essa base que o
discurso será melhor que o discurso de
seu filho será melhor
talvez nós tenhamos reuniões melhores
aulas melhores discursos melhores vídeos
melhores se tivermos focado esses três
pilares bom compartilhem informa que não
tem nenhuma relação com tecnologia isso
que eu tô falando divulguem para o filho
de vocês vocês estão trocando pelo tempo
de vida de alguém isso é reversível
aqui um exemplo claro disso de
compartilhamento de idéias boas práticas
chave pinto macedo marcelo machado
macedo marcelo machado a cobra sua mesmo
era roubada também me segure no agora
explica uma coisa que não sou eu quero
saber mas acho que a população toda quer
saber é como esse indivíduo conseguiu
invadir uma casa com um muro de três
metros de altura uma cerca elétrica 3
pitbull grades alarmes e câmeras de
segurança e da tribo empresa que faz a
segurança particular local o rapaz foi
preso e vai responder pelo crime mas não
sou obrigado a dar a entrevista não
muito menos vai ensinar a ensinar as
técnicas da minha profissão eu não e sim
eu estudei
espero que tenha ajudado vocês obrigado
bom dia brasil